okay I think we can get started
looks uh looks like we'll get uh
get it all done any case um I usually
have slides today this is a bit of an
experiment
um the uh idea is to um
basically give an orientation of a
fairly small topic but one which I think
is interesting and amusing
and then
um at opening up for discussion for
everybody who's here to participate
um those of you who are students at
Stanford uh please don't put up your
video
uh anyone else can put the video up or
not as they wish because uh of uh the uh
requirement that you'll be able to
attend anonymously if you're a student
at the University
um in any case the topic today is
intellectual property and artificial
intelligence
and it's one which is interested in an
amusement for the last um well I think
probably six months about six months ago
I sort of decided that we had uh had all
sorts of things change so let's let's do
this I'm gonna
automatically include all the standard
disclaimers about uh this is and that's
and thank the people who participated in
uh me informing me a little bit about
this
and I want to tell everybody that no
artificial intelligence program
participated in the preparation of this
talk
and then I thought about that a bit and
concluded that to the best of our
knowledge no no artificial intelligence
program participated in the preparation
but somewhere somehow out there in the
space
uh that might not be no longer true
and so sort of the conclusion I reached
six months ago was that the singularity
is almost here now if you don't know
about the singularity it's probably
not really
um
transparent what's going on but the
singularity is when the massive
computing power reaches uh a critical
point and it begins to operate on its
own
and in a sense the chat GPT and a number
of the other uh AI programs begin to
look like that might be the case they're
good enough so that
in some ways in some places it's very
very difficult to tell whether or not
they are they're real
um so all of a sudden our machine
learning is and artificial intelligence
are real and they are just another piece
of the toolkit that we get to use except
that they're not they're much more
powerful in some ways so the question
really that we're trying to address
today
is what happens next
uh uh and
as a
predictor of the future or rather a
forecaster of the future
I have not really a a real clue as to
what's going to happen
I think this is a very
significant point point where things are
changing rapidly and
we're going to see very major changes
now you may have different opinions of
that and if you do it would be really
nice to have those expressed today when
this turns into an open forum
um
intellectual properties arose a recent
acquisition in the uh in the space of
things people humans do but we we do
have
a fairly long standing
constitutional mandate for intellectual
property in the in the U.S
um
it's we have two kinds of protections
for intellectual property and uh they
are
[Music]
to promote the progress of Science and
the useful Arts by securing
and the mechanism which the Constitution
proposes as the right one for doing that
is securing one for limited times to
authors and inventors the exclusive
rights to their respective writings and
discoveries that is to say a monopoly
um we've evolved a number of different
kinds of protectable intellectual
property patents and copyrights being
the primary one trade secrets are are
somewhat different because unlike the uh
the previous two the patents in
copyright tree Secrets have to do with
how the information is acquired in some
sense we'll talk a little bit about that
but that's uh that's what it is patents
are what you can do with almost anything
there are very substantial
[Music]
um
there's a substantial uh
set of Law and and examples which show
that exactly how patents go together the
important thing is that Adams are now
first to file which says that you know
ongoing to research and development
needs to be patented and patented again
on a regular basis if you're disclosing
what you're doing to anybody it's only
it's only after you are you have it
under protection for example with a
provisional patent that you can really
disclose much of the contents of your
your research or development
um there are a variety of different
patents the only one that is significant
in some sense because it it's how things
get done is our utility patents
um now patents basically take a
collection of information and
um
eventually provide a preferred
embodiment for it at least this is a
traditional format and then
also a number of different claims and
these claims have particularly
particular constraints on them and
rights and
that needs to be unique in the world of
all previous thought which can be
difficult or can be uh straightforward
depending upon the field you're in
other things that can't be patented
discoveries scientific theories
mathematical methods uh aesthetic
creation
rules for performing a mental act the
presentation of information and the
procedure for surgical and therapeutic
treatment
uh you can't uh you can't uh patent uh
software and business methods that is
non-technical ones technical ones are
patentable to a certain extent can't
patent perpetual motion machines
inventions contrary to public morality
and now we have the reasonably acquired
Alice constraints
to say an abstract idea does not become
eligible for a patent simply because
it's being implemented on a generic
computer
copyrights are
lesser
the strong version of intellectual
property uh it uh protects ideas does
not protect ideas Concepts systems or
methods of doing something it protects
uh
something else it's what's there minus
all of those those things so that it it
is a
uh
the essence or an idea or expression of
the idea that is uh copyright not the
idea itself
so uh Regional works of Austin chip for
those done by people there are all sorts
of rules about how collecting
Collective groups can work together to
provide a collective work of authorship
by transferring rights in any case
copyrights are a relatively weaker form
of protection but one which is widely
used and of course when you write
anything a work of authorship is
automatically copyright
um
moves copyright law
stumbles on the separation of ideas and
expression
and uh because what it protects is
expression uh there's a lot of argument
about what constitutes expression and
what constitutes uh
ideas and uh it appears at least in the
experience I've had that that is going
to continue to be uh
that way and what we have to do in order
to uh to determine what what's
expression and what our ideas is go off
to uh court and litigate it
um there is a concept of fair use and uh
while the copyright gives the uh gives
everybody a
uh
because the author or the
owner of the copyright the right to
control access to things uh there are
uh there's a back door that allows some
access under rules or something called
fair use
trade secrets are quite a different
thing uh these are
secret and have to be maintained so uh
it has to confer a competitive Advantage
which usually means that there needs to
have been a
analysis uh on a financial basis with
like it's better to do it one way or
another the information is uh has to be
uh
[Music]
subject to reasonable efforts to keep
the secret
um
trade secrets are probably not something
that at least at this point
um are going to be part of the issues
with the artificial intelligence
the real fundamental question for today
is can AI programs create
is intelligence and creativity unique to
humans
I can artificial intelligences just
create something independent of human
effort
and that is
really important
um
question is should an algorithm or an AI
be granted to be comparison or should it
be able to apply for and inquire uh
patents or copyrights on work that it
generates
right now uh we'll see in a minute that
the the
agencies that create and provide patents
and copyright do not allow that but it's
an open question as to whether we should
allow that and that's I think going to
be something that is going to be fought
over uh aggressively in the last the
next few years one of the things we I
would like people to think about and
talk about is whether what the what the
implications are of allowing AI programs
to have the agency of uh doing uh their
own patents and so forth and is that
going to be a good thing or a bad thing
for our society
you remember back to the Constitutional
mandate the real uh purpose of
copyrights and patents is not to give
somebody a uh
a monopoly on a piece of intellectual
property but rather to allow that person
or those persons to
contribute some something to the overall
uh intellectual
intellectual uh
uh Bank of the society as a whole and
the trade that's made is you get
protection as a monopolist for a short
period of time and then you have to
provide an adequate description of the
invention or the uh the work itself uh
in for uh use after the copyright or
patent expires and if you do allow ai's
Works to be created uh who would own the
resolving works and inventions
um incidentally copyright
terms are often specified in terms of uh
the author's age or years from their
birth or something like of that deal and
um if ai's uh don't have the finite
lifetimes that's that's an interesting
question itself as to what what the term
of a uh of a
copyright for a work uh authorship by an
AI
um
there are lots of things we can talk
about
uh discussing uh uh should the AI be
regulated should an electoral property
uh have an ownership who owns it uh will
we soon find AI in everything
uh doing uh everything including
nefarious bees
um I'm told by a couple of people in the
security area that that's already doing
that that the chat gpg stuff is already
been Incorporated in some malicious
software
um
so the the thing is I'm really
interested in what the impact is and
since you're the uh the users or for
this technology uh you probably have a
better idea of what it is to uh to do a
lot
um
it's also it's also the thing that it
always comes down to when uh people
first encountered thinking about this is
the question is is are humans important
with creative process are if you can't
detect whether the output of the
creating process was created by a
machine or a uh a human uh doesn't make
any difference I think that's that's an
important
important point when you're trying to
argue that maybe the AIS should be
allowed to do their thing without the
interference or health of a human being
um right now the situation is is is is
exactly what you might expect for things
the
patent office does not accept inventions
by non-humans
uh the reasoning for that is several for
one of them being that since non-humans
can't sign the application uh the patent
office can't accept it
and then the copyright office is not
support AI authors
and uh just recently they
they uh they said that that was the case
and
um
several other organizations who
picked through copyright outside of the
US have also been rejecting uh things a
couple of countries have allowed for
copywriting of materials written by AIS
under the AIS identification but that is
not the common case at this point
and I think that's the end of the slide
so what I'd like to do now is to move to
uh an open Forum uh raise your hand or
whatever or just step in if there's a
there's a break and ask questions make
comments tell us tell me a little bit
about what you think the
the situation
ought to be I
have thought about the showtime so I
think I think the implications of uh of
the technology being used and being
somewhat autonomous are uh interesting
and uh perhaps somewhat disturbing the
um
the implica if you adopt that position
and note that the AI software is uh
similar to many other different kinds of
software and the the it looks to me like
the
uh
the AI model if it becomes propagating
that it becomes fairly simple to have
automatic misses and that's which are
not necessarily uh based on our current
AI models but I'm much simpler or much
more complicated programs which also
have the same agency and it is going to
change the relationship between what is
uh possible in in the intellectual
property Arena and who makes money on
things
um any case I'm going to drop the slides
down now
and open the uh the thing please
remember to turn on your microphone it's
uh if you're interested in saying
something okay
here we go
uh so there is a question who would
profit if I create some invention
creator of a AI or a guy who actually
asked that AI to do some invention or
it's maybe a poem for example scientific
I mean technology invention or whatever
well I I can't answer that uh what what
do you think would make it would make
sense
I don't know it's just new for me at
least for today
yeah I see okay well if you think about
it as we go on and you come back in if
you come up with a good answer I think I
think uh that's that's going to be one
of the more difficult ones uh
particularly since if you give agency to
the AIS and they can do work
then
it's possible
that
um the slavery or anti-slavery like
things go come and get brought in
because you're doing uh uh servile work
without pay uh for somebody else and I'm
not certain that that applies but it
certainly is an interesting thought I
thought
yeah right and we need to solve that as
as fast as possible because otherwise it
would be solved in courts
yes I think so and I think that I think
by the way that the this is going to be
dominant in the next uh
I think I think we'll have in every AI
this is and that's everywhere in the
next uh six to ten months to a year and
already you see it uh showing up in in
various places which
is a little surprising if you'll
remember when uh Benji uh mentzer uh
spoke he was talking about uh how um uh
the
patching of uh images together uh into
it into a seamless hole is now being
done with the use of AI and you can't
disassemble it in order to tell whether
or not it's faked or not
I think
I think thinking about this question as
well and the something that came up
was that there are currently some
licensing work because in in at present
artificial intelligence is a technology
so it is still not at the level of
Consciousness and Imitation Of
Consciousness does not mean that machine
has it for example the Turing test it
states that if machine can imitate human
therefore it is capable of human
thinking but it is important to remember
that there is a difference so syntax is
also the same as semantics as CR Johnson
as well and I agree with this opinion
but at the present since we view it more
as a technology or at least I do
there are more of a licensing program on
as well as currently you have to pay for
certain types of
um AI
and then you can own the work otherwise
the work belongs to the Creator on the
order of the company so there are also
some decentralized networks that include
AI so that's a little more complicated
but I think it would really depend on
the type of AI what it does and how we
use this work because there are open
licenses and for public use and not and
private so I think it would maybe depend
what is it and what the Creator decides
um
I think I think you I think you're right
here that's that's a a reasonable
position but
um
you're you're basically trying to set it
up in such a way that the current the
current ownership situation is is is is
is as uh
undisturbed as possible in a sense that
you you want to sort of maintain
licensing and uh ownership by companies
and that sort of thing and that may not
be the right thing to do
I think yeah
I mean I'm just curious about exactly
what what else what other options there
might be
okay so I understand your concern but
currently also the companies uh create
AI so it's more a private thing so it
definitely would be good to have some
government intervention I think at least
partially because also uh there may be
difference because I'm in Europe so we
have a little different legislation as
well as European commission currently
working on the AI policies so I'm not
sure 100 what the situation in U.S but I
think that it would be good process of
collaboration because it is a very
powerful technology it also involves a
lot of data so how this also data
collected and what it gives you as a
result
um I think it should be at least thought
together we should maybe set a common
goal but at the present since the
technology is made by private sector uh
I think at now there is a short-term
licensing but if we look in the future
of course maybe it's technology
progresses it may change and we have to
be aware of these changes and provide
new also changes on legislation or our
ideas how do we perceive the technology
particular AI as well yes okay great
anybody else there
yeah
oh go ahead yes yeah sorry
um the question was so I'll reference uh
a number of cases specifically
um the case in which that um I think it
was a macaque took a picture of itself
uh selfie and then uh the owners of the
camera who had let the the monkey uh get
a handle of it and then take a picture
of it
um there you go that's it yeah uh
try to um except copyright it over the
images that the um that the primate took
of itself and then Peta sued uh the
people who tried to for a violation of
this uh this primates uh copyrights and
and uh it was based on uh actually core
findings that if it's not I mean yes the
copyright office rejected the
proposition but at the same time the
courts rejected the proposition of
non-human of any sort can exert any kind
of copyright
so that's in the United States at least
the jurisprudence is pretty
um pretty unequivocal about that there
has been no there's no no successful
challenges so that's to that formulation
uh but the only other way in which um
the idea of ownership has been addressed
Mary Rosenberger uh who is the uh lee
Council
for the authors Guild of the United
States uh in comments to the copyright
office suggested that perhaps two
solutions could be found that whatever
um
analogous to the solutions found in the
monkey case which were that if the
photographer set the f-stop that's or
the is whatever if the photographer
someone just intervene in any way then
by extension it is the photographer's
copyright so that's what part of the
rationale is why the course found in
favor of the uh owners of the camera who
had put that in so I think that answers
the question as to whether copyright in
the United States jurisprudence is
pretty unequivocal about that Mary
suggested that um
any work of any copier uh any work novel
work over which there is no overfitting
or plagiarism or anything like that uh
as long as a human being had some hand
in it even if it was transfer learning
fine tuning even if the model showed up
uh you know pre-trained and whatever
that constitutes copyrights for a human
and that's the that's the entity that
gets the copyrights uh so Paul reinitz
at getty who is the head of advocacy
who's been sitting uh he's also a
colleague of mine who've said and Paul
on panels with his determination is his
and we debate because his determination
is that um
now the question is how much input is
the the metric by which courts should
award
if not then it either the the thing was
a violation the creation is a violation
or goes into the public domain so now a
lot of policy makers are trying to find
where's the magic spot where
you know you got just this is just right
human intervention for it to constitute
human creation uh and that's a relative
you know people who are copyright owners
are going to want more input from a
human before others are going to want a
lot less like I put a dot somewhere and
that's enough
um so I think that's uh from my
understanding and I would I would I
would encourage like I'm gonna put in
the link on Mary rottenberger's
rosenberger's uh comments to the
copywriter Illuminating in this regard
and she would like to have licensing on
any AI so kind of like the AAA the h i a
like the human recording act the HRA
where
you know they passed on all
manufacturers of uh digital audio tape
recorders had to pay a licensing fee
before the object got in the market so
the copyrighters are advocating for that
everybody anybody who makes an AI Tech
needs to pay a license to like anybody
how do you deal with the fact that
everything that's written as every work
of authorship by a human being is
automatically copyright
correct uh and it's sort of like you
invented technology that could
potentially in the process of its
operation violate copyrights therefore
if you invaded if you invented such a
technology you are you have to pay a
license to the original to whatever
content you wish to to use the musicians
the authors uh you know uh Jack Valente
must be rising from the dead he's so
happy it's at least you know he was the
former lead counsel for the ra uh the
music I'm Excuse me the industry right
so he's he's the guy whose family said
something so egregious in front of
Congress it was not even it was not even
it's not even worth comment if you want
to know you're gonna look it up
um so that's my my uh my comment on that
I think it's uh
it's just not going to happen the
jurisprudence is pretty
pretty solid yeah so do you think you
think that the uh the efficacy of the
AIS will get impacted all by the uh the
rush to having uh rules about how how
the uh intellectual property is managed
I think what's going to happen it's
going to be a chilling effect I think um
unless the tech industry doesn't get
because I'll tell you Getty is in Europe
my Paul uh from Getty is in Europe
advocating for this kind of uh
governance and they're doing it in the
United States and um I don't see tech
companies really doing anything uh well
they're doing something but they're not
in there in the room really fighting in
my opinion so so are you at would you
advocate for tech companies doing
advocating for much looser or a much
tighter control on the uh I think um
there's gonna have to be a middle ground
I think Mary rottenberger's uh
comments on let's say the amino insist
thesis that if you start treating it
like on menu instances anything that it
makes is a work for hire in it and so
whether it's a patent so anything on AI
makes becomes a work for hire and it's
your manual answers they just helped you
and in that way
um I think it's a good way it becomes
less of a chilling effect people are
more willing to say well okay I I had a
a help as opposed to well yeah I did
most of it and then nobody gets to
benefit from
um the Monopoly which was supposed to be
an incentive I think that that covers it
usually recently a number of papers have
been submitted into journals
where the AI program was left as a as a
as a co-author
rejected them because they say only
human authors
right I think it's going to be a
normative like different fields
Publications will will have different
Norms that evolve but as a matter of law
uh the boundaries are pretty
are pretty
um well defined and you believe that the
boundaries of law will prevail
I I would think the argument would have
to be a common goods argument
um I think something I I've spoken other
intellectual property attorneys who
suggest that maybe a Nash equilibrium or
a Nash equilibrium or those kinds of
economic studies of markets suggest that
actually a looser copyright a looser
intellectual property regime is better
for the market as a whole and I think
that argument can be made for AI since
it's the potential to mass produce high
quality functional tools so and the
market will benefit so it sort of it
inoculates against The Chicago School uh
jurists right and then also uh and give
some support to the incentivize and
progress of the useful Arts Camp yeah
okay great
thank you
the Constitutional mandate is that
there's a bargain here that we will give
you a monopoly if you submit to the um
to the to the public domain uh
eventually right so we'll give you a
limited time uh so that's essentially
incentivizing authors and patents and
mentors to be able to put their things
out so that incentive
um is missing from machines machines
don't need incentives to be able to
create and in fact the machines can spit
out millions and billions of things
whereas humans can't do even a fraction
of that so my thought is that
constitutionally we don't have a way
like we don't need to incentivize
machines to blankets the world with
copyrightable things and patentable
things
um that incentive uh does isn't needed
so as my personal example I've created a
a machine to spit out in copyright 417
billion Melodies
um I once they're written to a fixed
tangible medium those are are now
copyrighted right under the burn
convention
um so are all 417 billion of my Melodies
copyrightable I set the parameters and
that's the previous speaker just talked
about the f-stop right so I created the
f-stop I said here are the parameters of
I want Doremi Faso latido and then I
said and repeat this many notes and then
it spit out 417 billion Melodies
um do I have I know closed off every
possible Melody that's ever been and
ever can be
um if any can I sue now people for every
possible Melody I think the answer to
that clearly is no because my machine
didn't need the incentive the
Constitutional incentive to be able to
respond to be able to you know get a
monopoly of life of the author plus 70
years or for uh for a corporate it's a
120 years if I'm remembering correctly
95 or 120 years
yeah so none of those incentives is
necessary for the machine so I would
argue that the only real good answer to
on the output is no copyright
um because machines don't need
incentives on the input on what the
machines like the llms or the large
language models like gbt and Bart Etc
what they input if you look at the way
the technology is done they're ingesting
the ideas and not the expressions of
those ideas
um so they're spread their eyes they're
pulling in the ideas of uh what is uh
you know what is uh a good thing what is
a bad thing what is a car what is a
truck uh and it puts all those things in
Vector space in a mathematical model and
it jettison's the expressions of those
ideas it merely keeps those ideas
themselves and then outputs new
expressions of those ideas so to the to
the previous person's discussion about
maybe we need to put a tax on all AI
systems
um the AI system ingests you know Grapes
of Wrath but it doesn't keep grades of
breath in the in the system instead it
just takes the ideas from Grapes of
Wrath and then jettison's that
expression and then Maps those ideas
with all the thousands or millions of
other books uh and then uh the
expression doesn't matter the ideas are
the only things that matter so I would
say that uh that really there's uh
there's really no reason to have a home
recording act because uh if you look at
the Google Scholar uh case that's the
author's Guild versus Google in the
second circuit they said that it's fair
use
because you uh we uh you can uh it's for
a transformative use to be able to say
I'm I Google am indexing all of these
books and I Google can reproduce three
or four pages of verbatim text from
those books and that is for use as
transformative compare that with the
large language models that again aren't
even taking those expressions of those
books not even taking three pages of
those expressions but rather it's just
taking the ideas of those books and then
reconstituting ideas not Expressions but
reconstituting ideas there so if fair
use under Google Books then wouldn't it
also be fair use under large language
models yeah the the Google books has
been argued to be
invasive and uh
um non
non-conforming to copyright models but
yeah I agree with you I think that it's
right uh it's it's interesting that you
see this as a separation of idea uh from
the expression uh in terms of building
the knowledge base in which all of these
things are are based and it's it's very
interesting
I I think that I it's because if you
look at the models the large language
models there is not an expression to be
found in those models there's merely
ideas it takes in Vector space it takes
the idea of Bob dylanism right it takes
the idea of you know uh of any human
author and uh it doesn't it doesn't have
any Bob Dylan's lyrics in the system it
merely has the idea of what Bob Dylan uh
his use of language right uh so in
anyway there is not not an expression to
be found
um
okay that's great
so uh maybe I should also introduce
myself a little um I'm from Poland uh
University of Yao stock close to Warsaw
so uh yeah I just to uh make it clear
and through this muscle so a couple of
points that I mentioned here I think
that uh reference to ideas and
expressions may also have a little
deeper connection to syntax and
semantics uh of artificial intelligence
so that artificial intelligence at least
as currently seen it's shuffling this
um
shuffling the symbols physical symbols
but it doesn't have mental content
attached to it so when I say I like ice
cream so we as people have mental
content attached what is it ice cream so
I think what it also uh implies here is
that the machine is not kinda have this
deeper understanding but it is shuffling
the information the data and I think
also uh maybe regarding the authorship
point I will start from the end uh from
because I made a couple of notes so uh
maybe it's not authorship that we can
grant but a mansion so we can raise an
awareness that this technology has
participated in creation of this and
that so because authorship implies a
moral status and currently only humans
have moral status
of course there were proposition in
European Commission of electronical
persons or electronic persons but it was
kept just as an idea so it didn't come
into life as an actual uh concept so
maybe not yet and maybe not in very
close future but as I mentioned the idea
of moral status which also uh I think
you called as a legal personhood
I I assume it's related so uh there is a
deeper ontological question so what is
machine and how do we see it do we see
it as a like
conscious or unconscious because we have
animals as well we have children whose
creation for example uh is kind of uh
under parent guidance or animals when
they create it kind of Legally belongs
to the owner of the animal so where the
position artificial intelligence and
whether we should position it on the
scale of living
or spectrum because we also have to
understand the living beings uh because
non-living come into play as well so
it's important to think it through I
guess and um
yes regards in the free market that uh
mentioned I think it's uh he mentioned
exactly the looser control and I guess
the social control is related to free
market
but there is an
um possible challenge or maybe even an
issue that free market can lead to
uh autocratic
um
behavior in the sense that big companies
own it like currently we have uh we we
have a free market economy mostly you
know in almost everywhere and um
the thing is that now the big
corporations control our for example
media like Facebook who is meta so they
own many things as well as other
companies that own uh so of course I
find that governmental intervention is
necessary but not like that they control
everything but a certain degree of uh
mix of support and just guidance how do
we guide the ethically
um
development ethical development of
artificial intelligence which also
matters in those questions because
ethics is uh can be both as a well-being
for human and understanding how the
grand authorship come to make it right
do you think it's possible to write a a
description of whatever what an ethical
pursuing and a ethical way I could
actually be
so there is of course this is a very big
question how do we express our moral
things how do we can compute it we can't
explain the moral to each other to
humans how we explain it to machine into
the language of machine so currently
there are ethical ideas what AI could
look like which is uh kind of respectful
in a sense to privacy uh it also can be
that a collection of data the equality
so it's not biased which is very
important it's a very big topic right
now in artificial intelligence uh
avoidance of bias and because when
artificial intelligence is biased it
reproduces inequality when it's put in a
world it can end up very not well so
there is Big fear that artificial
intelligence not not even fear but idea
that artificial intelligence May harm us
not because it's too smart and will
outsmart us but because it's not smart
enough
so and it will reinforce these issues
that we have so question of ethics of
artificial intelligence is questions
about us so I think in all of these
questions is how do we actually perceive
artificial intelligence and how do we
position it with ourselves because we
make it along and this is a technology
so what place does it have of course we
can't really answer this all now and
maybe not many Minds come together and
they still consulted but it's something
to look forward to and uh yeah so the
question uh coming back to it so what is
ethical I could be well we can now maybe
realize the main points but exact
ethical ideas I'm not sure even if we
can express them but we can understand
some uh what is good more or less what
is um what is beneficial what is uh
non-beneficial so this is what we can
also understand but also another Point
who doesn't benefit so I think it's all
for now I'm sorry
it's it's interesting that you
that you're in your UK chose that
particular point of view I think
you you seem you've seen
to thought through this this whole issue
rather rather nicely and you seem you
seem to be fairly certain that some of
these things can be done and yet those
of us who've tried feel is really hard
so I think I think I think it's we what
you're saying is that this is this is a
goal not a place where we are at the
moment
yeah definitely there is something to
work uh to over to it is a new
technology but it's not like it's on you
that artificial intelligence is uh
something just came up it's been very
long actually quite long in history or
even if not artificial intelligences we
have today the idea of artificial
intelligence being for long and um what
I mean that indeed we have a goal to
work because it's like when uh first
internet came it was a big change so how
did internet involve what was done for
this so I see it kind of shift similar
to the internet uh but it still has its
own things and um yeah and thank you for
pointing out I'm actually writing my
thesis on this topic and I study
philosophy and ethics so maybe this is
where my perspective coming from as well
yes
all right do we have any more comments
out there yes I would like to learn that
uh any kind of uh attempt to buy into
the person to Legal moral or ethical
issues is very dangerous because you and
me may have a different view on what is
moral uh what is legal what is ethical
that's first the second one I just want
to remind you that there is a old test
proposed about Consciousness from Martin
Minsky
artificial intelligence is artificial
intelligence if you can't
differentiate it from another human
okay don't remember exact wording but if
it's kind of
and finally I would like to maintain
that there are two levels of that and it
seems like we sleep into a person and a
human
but in currently in many development in
technology assumes artificial
intelligence and much less than that
Psalm 2
which could help to produce inventions
or
development or whatever
so for that reason it's a way
interesting who would own the result
because one company May produce two
even actually more companies May produce
it true and another company may just use
that tool to create invention or some
kind of
work which may be copyrighted or
whatever who own this
that's the issue because
if we default that
tool creator
copyrights they have a right on
copyright it's a path to hell
basically in my mind
um
otherwise it's actually
where two creators were spent a very big
efforts to make that working
uh
so
some I mean some Thin Line need to be
put here maybe right just think about
that if there is no explicit uh legal
agreement between two Creator and uh
user of that true
when by default the
right of work belongs to a user
yeah again I'm talking about what is
usually assumed Reddit now what is
artificial intelligence it's not about
human or whatever whatever
we
close to that but we still don't don't
do not jump to this
I mean to have human in a computer you
know in somewhere
okay okay please go ahead
do you have a comment here
uh yeah so why we were talking about
this because it was actually a question
how do we uh whether the
uh artificial intelligence should be
given a legume personhood and how they
perceive it so this is a reason why I
opened uh the discussion uh but
I will start from the beginning so we
don't know uh what is moral for everyone
therefore we should not be concerned
with this it's I find that uh quite uh I
don't know how to explain but we should
not give up on the morality and ethics
if we have a differences it's like we it
is commonly perceived that murder for
example is not good
it is unethical so to say in a softer
sense so it is something common most of
us understand it
and we just should look toward Common
Grounds of course it may not be so
simple also artificial intelligence
technology is not fully International so
each country has their own but
International technology should have uh
also aim for the international standards
which is very important in the
development as well as copyright and the
in terms of law
so uh the second about the uh argument
of Minsky so whether if machine can
imitate Consciousness does it has
Consciousness it is deterring test as
well uh what states it and as I
mentioned before imitation is not
Recreation
so Imitation Of Consciousness does not
mean you have Consciousness just because
you can imitate it very well
sorry for interrupting you here
um but you can say that it is imitation
if you cannot detect that you cannot say
okay but
the same it's like
um I can produce such a beautiful
artificial flower it won't be able to
distinguish it's real
does it make it real
you don't know
you don't know I don't know as a
customer but the Creator knows
so the fact of ontology of its uh
creation is known it is artificial
it's not real
but
it may be many reasons for Creator to
hide that or whatever
and it's also a rice it's also as an
issue if women bear
create a child
what is it
this is a different question
for you it may look similar or same but
it is very different uh women don't give
birth to artificial children uh this is
a living human being who possess a full
moral status like uh you and me I guess
so uh this is totally another topic but
uh let's come back to the artificial
intelligence and the example of flower
so indeed they may hide it but it
doesn't change the fact that it is
artificial okay let's assume that the
creator of artificial flower dies
diet
you don't know Creator diet he don't
live anymore
this is already some sort of fairy tale
or a story but or another you have a
flower you cannot ask Creator because
Creator died
so this is already certain I don't know
I had an idea of creation of artificial
thing
does not make it real whether out or die
whether it was hidden whether it was
sent to space I don't know the thing if
it's artificial it doesn't make it real
I hope it's quite clear
the third point is that we as uh
mentioned the beginning that
um we moved over the other idea of moral
status of artificial intelligence but
indeed it's important to understand how
it is just a technology it's complicated
powerful technology so it is important
to understand how we deal with it now
but it's also important to keep in mind
the possible changes so certain
perspective to the Future should be kept
the how it may change but we need to
focus at present because going too much
into what it could be even we never May
ever reach Singularity it may not ever
happen there are ideas like that so and
it is quite prevailing so we have to
focus issues we have now like bias and
artificial intelligence the ownership
authorship
and the picture so which is again the
question of ownership and authorship
because if it's such powerful technology
owned by single like one two companies
what what it's it's such a big issue
that
um because such technology will be owned
by a single person who can basically
decide and reinforce wherever they
desire which is I think important to
regulate
thank you I think that's that's
definitely an issue here and that's uh
one of the one of the big questions that
we have is that we need to somehow
arrange that this technology is widely
available to everybody without much
concern about their economic status and
relationship with other entities
and uh or do we just allow the large
monolithic companies to battle over the
uh intellects of the of the populace
which interact with these AIS
Le I don't know it's a it's a it's a
difficult question
it's uh it's in it's exactly what we're
trying to figure out I know and the
thing is I don't think we have a whole
lot of time I think that this is a
powerful enough technology that we'll
see it moving rather rapidly into almost
everything we do and I don't know
whether it were too late to actually
build a control system for it or not
it's it's hard for Venice I have other
other response uh points which are I
think I think uh the second paper I
posted on there for I think that will be
right up your alley When you mention
about the vectorization the findings of
the courts when when they found was the
transformation between the content so
the in the courts the only people really
making a stink really are intellectual
property owners existing intellectual
property owners that are obsessing
really like staying up at night and hang
ringing that someone used in their
training Corpus or their transfer
learning Corpus call copyrighted Goods
right and uh they and by in by a
function of their process made copies
and used those as inspiration uh for the
generating the model and so the model is
in a sense has the vibe right kind of
like Billy Joel had the vibe of Bob
Dylan when he's saying piano man because
it sounds a lot like tambourine man
right so these so it's almost a sense of
the human influence in transfer learning
but the copyright owners would be trying
to prevent that because there was an
actual objective copying made but the
corresponder the transformation to a
data Matrix like a like a vectorization
of that is enough of a transformation
for it to be uh transformative and
therefore
uh fair use is all good so how do you
define Transformers just because that's
the difference yeah it's always been a
it's always kind of a slippery slope
between transformative work and
derivative work derivative work is a
like the original enough and this can be
subjective and it depends on the type of
content we're using if it's a book A
Story versus a movie versus a song right
different types it is this is a tonal
structure the same uh the sound
progressions are the notes progressions
the same for how many bars uh and you
have these ecologists who go through an
entire piece just to find enough overlap
enough overfit to blame uh whoever made
the new song the three AI or on their
own uh to claim copyright violation uh
so it varies on content on the on the on
the type of media we're talking about
like what is
um derivative or versus transformative
uh in the case of data when content
becomes a data form it is transformed
the courts did not extrapolate to other
media forms like film or music but it is
a logical extension of the reasoning
that you could indeed do that
um and that really puts a breaks on
copyright owners arguments against uh
you know against anyone using Ai and
makes the immune systems a lot more
palatable right otherwise
um they'll just sort of
you know just kind of never get anywhere
it would be an argument that goes and
doesn't go anywhere but to answer the
question uh about Moral Moral rights I'm
assuming you're referencing con that's
the last time I heard it in the legal uh
philosophy and it was the moral rights
and those are Continental ideas at least
in in the U.S and the UK that's a
different story right and that's it's
applicable equitability to an extension
of the self right so in the United
States the self ends where the self ends
right and privacy laws May extend that
to health like HIPAA or whatever but so
that the moral rights argument in the
United States and uh might be a hard
sell I think you're right a much easier
sell uh in the UK in in the content well
uh European copyright law has a has a
concept from France a moral right which
is a right that cannot be uh sold or
taken away correct and it's an extent
and it goes beyond it goes into
personhood that anything that a person
like your Visage uh the things that you
make it's like you put your soul into it
I mean they took that metaphor literally
right so it's it's extension of the
person uh but I don't think if you're
gonna think about it internationally
we'll run into the same things uh kinds
of conundrums that we get into in
privacy right the gdpr provides the
kinds of protections for uh European
citizenship data that uh we don't afford
here for um American citizens so we
we're in this weird space like well
are we going to become Divergent in our
International treaty obligations to
observe copyright right if we can't
agree on whether the AI uh even by using
an original work to learn to make its
own original Works has in fact violated
the moral rights of an existing author
or uh person or photographer
so that's a that's a more but a legal
person is a different definition than a
moral person and
we were talking about two different
things it seems like if we're going to
start thinking about AI as a moral
person we have to do that first in an
argument that we in a way that we can
all get on board and then try to sell
that to the policy makers who are just
thinking of legal persons
um otherwise they'll be like well that's
a nice argument congratulations but you
know it has it's not practical or and so
they'll build a mirror it's just
somebody you really want to live leave
to the policy makers to decide no but we
need to get on it because we need to get
on it right because people are doing it
highly paid attorneys for the copyright
owner industry and media Industries are
on it yes I know you know
so I hope you enjoy that one I think
your point is quite correct that this is
um the vectorization changes what that
thing is yeah well the the
transformational transformational change
is one of the the arguments uh for uh
allowing fair use
and uh it's not
then it's not my it's still case laws
and not been migrated into the actual uh
actual copyright law itself I don't
believe right yeah so it's a
transformative if something is fun to be
transformative any use therefore the use
of the original content you may copies
you performed it on it doesn't matter it
was fair because at the out at the other
end you produce something unique but
also wanted to point out if uh the
courts that found for the rationale
behind vectorization of content into
Data also forgot to cycle back to the
market so in other words what if I take
a corpus of music and I design and I you
know I transfer learn something and the
thing makes music right and then I take
that music and sell it back in the same
Market in which I drew the music from
that was never addressed in in the
findings of the Court that's a
that's the kind of words waiting to be
open and it will be um
that will be open you have your hand up
go for it
uh I think uh almost first so I can go
out oh he's over there okay
I'm looking forward to reading that uh
that article uh as soon as I'm in front
of a machine uh to the second Point
there's another analogy uh with ram you
remember in the night the late 1990s and
early 2000s there was a copy made in Ram
but it was a transitory copy uh it was
there and then it's gone similar with
vectorization right you've vectorized
the music and then you jettisoned the
expression right all that's left is a
residual ideas so anyway that's all I
wanted to say that that's a second
analogy of why this is not a copy of the
original and to the third point about uh
essentially uh a snake eating its own
tail where the machine is going to eat
more of the machine's output which is
going to eat more of the machine's
output uh that is something that yeah I
worry about millions and trillions of
monkeys typing Shakespeare right and
then we just add the outputs uh just
merely mush uh but yeah that's that's
another reason why the output should not
be copyrightable
okay
that's an interesting thought okay up
next I guess
uh yeah so I I've had an idea uh during
the first talk and he was mentioning
this uh also a question authorship and
um how do we uh manage this on Gratis so
I was thinking maybe about
um
clearly or um
uh pointing out very kind of in a clear
manner that artificial intelligence
technology is present and I think it's
also easier in in terms of legal
reinforcement
so in this sense we may not okay deal on
who is the author whether AI is the
author but we can make it clear that it
has participated
another further step could be we could
mention uh what the percentage that
artificial intelligence contribute it
may also not be as like accurate like
67.5 or something but it could be like
60 to 70 30 to 40 something like that so
this is the idea I had
that we should not hide the fact that
technology as artificial intelligence
participate
but uh show it and I think again it's
maybe easier to legally reinforce since
it doesn't require us to deal what is AI
and should we give it authorship well we
can consider it from a more technical uh
point of view and say yes it is just a
technology maybe at present and we just
need to show it has taken part because
it also influenced our Judgment of the
work
so how do we perceive the work
especially why percentage is important
if artificial intelligence correct 90
percent and human input is done we may
question like what is the input of
course it may be significant because
guidance management is also a work and
sometimes uh very very significant which
creates actually the flow
so uh yes this is the idea uh I got
during the talk and uh yes I think I had
another Point ah also mentioned about
the circularity that AI keeps feeding on
machine indeed I think this is where the
significant human element comes into
play that we need actually create ideas
more like human ideas because of course
big part of our history and knowledge is
combining knowledge previous knowledge
into new one and then into new one so
this kind of mixing and matching but
there's also something creation of new
which machine may not able to do of
course it takes time to explore what it
can what it cannot what we can what we
cannot uh so also it may not should be
seen as competition with machine
but we should maybe work together toward
a common goal whether human or machine
achieves it first we set it higher than
so this is one of the things that we
have in a western Culture The Narrative
of competition of technology and human
uh which also can be seen in the uh
times like
like uh can't cancer uh philosophy and
also Transcendence which also goes back
to Plato uh so go and Beyond human self
but it's all right a little bit
different but still interconnected that
um yes this kind of difference again
what makes us human but back to the
topic uh more concrete and present
because it's all about human nature as
well but uh yeah so awareness
pointing it out percentage
advice and not at the best just saying
it has taken place and we should um uh
show it and yes of course it may all
seem very confusing and difficult as far
as implementing ethics it's very
important but we should not give up this
is why we're here this is why we're
working on this and thinking so we
should not give up when it seems
challenging because through this
challenge we will achieve something
great well I think I think we have an
opportunity to to make a very large
difference in how this shift to
technology is when it's going to impact
everything else
and my concern is that right now uh the
drive is too bigger and greater profits
for larger organizations
and uh increasing the cost of uh being
of existence for people who are in the
middle and lower range of things and
maybe that's not the ideal thing to do
and so I think we need to to to examine
what is possible
because we have this
well I I think I think the uh the uh
gpg chat is really it's magical
it's also wrong sometimes
I mean because it says it works only the
semiotics of the of the internal data
that's been stored and not upon any
understanding of what's really happening
and that may be the real difference
between AIS and uh humans for quite a
while
um but
if you can't tell the difference between
an AI and a human by asking questions uh
uh it's sort of hard to say that they're
very different
you know we're experimentalists in the
way we deal with the universe
and so we need to work out
go ahead
I believe that Turing test is still
valid so it can be seen as you mentioned
but we can't distinguish not as
um test for existing that it is real but
as a evaluative test that it is good
technology if it can replicate it so
well it means it's it's very good so it
would be more on an assessment
evaluative side rather than saying that
it's actually has something of course it
may have but as for example John crl
pointed out creates unconsciousness
takes something more than just syntax
which you mentioned shuffling also this
idea is that it doesn't have
understanding which is semantics
attaching metal content so uh yes it can
be very powerful as I mentioned before
and it's more can be to the side of
assessment again
so uh yes I think this is pretty much
okay
it is I want to send a link so I
mentioned that uh Paul my buddy Paul is
working for Getty Images and he's in
Europe trying to get uh uh some sort of
Regulation and I'm gonna send this link
up so a lot of the Getty Images are not
the Getty folks are now having uh models
sign consent forms that they're
Biometrics their images may be used for
biometric or AI training right so this
is like but that's an extension of the
moral person right because well wait a
minute right so so it's very clear that
agencies advocating for this sort of
control they are going to leverage that
argument you might want to you might
want to review some of their position
papers because it might give you
uh some some uh ammunition for your
argument right to to create a much more
um
well
I guess not to argue for artificial
intelligence uh personhood but rather
that
uh
well I guess that people that that there
is some form of extension of the moral
rights and that is enough to give
artificial intelligence put it put some
sort of
regulatory fence around it uh in the way
copyright may not be the best regulatory
offense it's it has showing effects and
well there are there are people who've
been arguing that we should have a a
different category of intellectual
property which is that created by ai's
or or make a artificial intelligence of
public utility uh kind of like telephone
uh lines and electricity
well yeah so our experience with cell
phone companies and power companies is
not that's great yeah it took a few
decades to get a hand of that right I
wonder though I mean that we're talking
a kind of quasi-personhood for machines
uh but at this point they're all tools
right uh this is a tool that I and when
I created my 417 billion Melodies I hit
a button and then it output right so I I
it is not an agent of me it is merely a
tool much like a word processor as a
tool so I think I think we're getting
ahead of ourselves to say that it it's
uh it's fully autonomous because it's
not so I think that's that's thing
number one thing number two is that we
have kind of quasi-autonomous bots
already uh if this happens then that I
do this right uh so that is you know if
if the stock price dips below this then
sell my thing right uh is there autonomy
there well no I mean it's still a tool
right uh but it but it seems autonomous
because it's doing it by itself so
anyway so I mostly I'm thinking this
this idea of providing personhood for
the machine I think that's putting our
you know going over our skis a bit I
don't think we're quite There Yet the
second thing I'm talking I I maybe for
somebody else was talking about to what
extent is there human additions to the
machine created Works uh and so I would
say that um that that's really tricky
because uh I you know you can go to
boomi.com uh and say I want an
electronic dance music that's 120 beats
per minute and it outputs a fully uh
realized song
um that under my proposition is is fully
machine created therefore on
copyrightable if I change one quarter
note
um is that does that make it
copyrightable same thing with chat gbt
right if I change one letter or if I
change a punctuation mark right is that
now copyrightable uh and putting a
threshold on human contribution to a
machine created work I think it's uh
that's that's Folly I think it's worse
than that I think it's criminal that's
different well I mean our feelings on it
are notwithstanding our our I mean I I
hear you in the corner the way that
things are going those are irrelevant on
how we feel about it relevant uh the
copy owners are going to want
humans to have a lot of input before
they can they can have the copyright but
people using AI to be creative or to
have stuff done quicker maybe get a
story started want minimal like yeah a
space something uh and which leads me to
an analog if you're a fans of literature
um Tom Wolf wrote oh you can never go
home again but his relationship with his
other was quite in was quite intimate
they were quite good friends and his
editor uh did a lot of work to shape
uh wolves so to show the final product
right so is should his editor have been
a co-creator of that we never we just
put the editor was there we don't
realize how much work creative work
actually editors do good editors
so the analog in our life is that the
amenances are someone who works a lot
doesn't you know if you said if you were
the first to get the ideas on paper or
even put a dot in anything that's
subsequent
is someone helping you but you're the
original right so I think the analog in
real life uh in between humans exists
and it's just an extension of that
that's right and if Tom Wolf didn't
disclose that editor the copyright
office would never know that that was
and that's another question right and so
I asked my attorney friends I said so
we're going to get subpoenas to look
into people's hard drives to see if
they're there's their training corpora
had copyrighted Works they're going to
hit delete right or they're gonna you
know they're gonna fry their it's gonna
vanish right the thing is to copyrighted
works that are used in some sort of
information knowledge base that's used
to drive to drive things like chat GPT
is is is uh is a reduction it's it's
been decomposed into pieces that are
very small and mixed with other pieces
and uh structure discovered amongst that
and it's not at all clear that that
there's much of the actual original
copyrighted material there
I 100 agree and I would also say that uh
if if I went to booby.com exported a
thing uh and then filed it with the
copyright office they would not know
that it was machine created right the
reason that thaler in the thaler lawsuit
got dinged is because thaler said yeah
the machine created it if I don't
disclose that they're not going to know
so number one no legal obligations right
no legal obligations to disclose that's
right so so number one is the copyright
office going to ask hey is it is there
any amount of machine creatable portion
of this that's maybe one one way to out
of this
um the other thing too is that uh if I
file with a copyright office they don't
ask I get a presumption of copyright on
the thing that I've just created if I
sue somebody over that thing
um then they don't know that that was
mission created right and so the that am
I going to be able am I going to be
required to disclose maybe in a
deposition that uh how what percentage
of this uh was machine created therefore
uncopyrightable anyway
I mean I I could lie right you may not
know I mean oh right right yes sure what
percentage is that who's coming go ahead
uh yeah I might try maybe to address it
from the last so the question also
editors how much actually the one person
may put work into work
um their knowledge and their uh skills
while the other one is praised so this
is common even among humans and it's
part of the research Integrity or just a
general uh publishing Integrity that you
should also make authors in right order
uh if it's scientific paper and uh like
that you should actually assign
otherwise it is a fraud or a
misrepresentation uh which is also not
good
and uh yeah another question uh that was
before is that
um we already kind of currently agreed I
think it is also more widely agreed that
it is at the technology it is technology
it is not the person uh artificial
intelligence as pointed out and it is
not fully autonomous indeed
uh yet the consequences that artificial
intelligence already do has uh ethical
implications on humans on us for example
self-driving cars so of course here is a
topic more of the copyrights but it's
also important on this more simple
example how ethical ideas actually can
be significant also in copyrights
because
um it may be more intricate but ethical
um uh ideas are very important in
artificial intelligence how it's built
and how it operates because as I
mentioned it collects data and uses this
data so how it will be used because also
it's important to think of artificial
intelligence not only as author it also
present in governmental systems for
example Compass artificial intelligence
algorithm that helps in courts to
convict or either make certain decision
for the court so it is also not only
about authorship it's also about the
court system and how it is embedded in
the government
which also think important thing so uh
yes another uh thing was I mentioned
about limiting AI data how it feeds on
it so of course model release forms is
very popular uh thing uh which means
that model may not give consent and
their photos were used this is uh very
popular or so not uh before artificial
intelligence
and still is reinforced by artificial
intelligence so one idea that I also had
is that maybe we could put certain
lemons how AI fits on the data because
in art it's very big issue in terms of
copyrights and ownership when AI copy
styles of artists and this artists lose
their income because people it's they
they can just order from artificial
intelligence for much lower price in any
way they want and that they have to pay
artists while machine fit on artist
style so
I think it's a fraud but I don't know
how to solve it yet but uh yeah so maybe
there could be limits how it feeds on
data so either say that collaboration
with artists so we use your style we
give you some fee for this so uh you
have this system of payment and the
contract which is I find very favorable
but it's also important to understand
when AI feeds on someone's style and
when not so it's so hard to find Styles
yes
for example there's a uh
provision in the copyright law that says
you cannot copyright a font
mm-hmm and the reason you can't
copyright a thought is that it's not
possible uh in any reasonable technology
to compare one font to another
in the it is so but certain also
Artistic Styles they're so recognizable
like Picasso for example yes of course
uh like uh it may be a little bit more
free in terms of Picasso but there are
modern artists who actually experience
this because their style is so distinct
uh like there was uh numbers in Spanish
artists who has such also abstract
um type of style and artificial
intelligence it became really popular
many people tried to recreate it so this
is more modern context so how it copies
uh the Styles uh yeah I saw it but I
wonder though the uh the style if I as a
human uh sound like Bob Dylan uh so I
sing in the style of Bob Dylan Bob Dylan
can't sue me for copyright infringement
uh because that's uh you know how many
singers sound like Bob Dylan right how
many how many people look like uh you
know painted like Matisse right so the
style of somebody is not copy writable
so similarly if a machine copies the
style of something is that copyrightable
and I'd argue no right because it is the
idea of Matisse it is the idea of
Picasso it is the idea of Bob Dylan and
again ideas are not copyrightable only
the expressions of those ideas so as
long as I'm not copying the expression
of Bob Dylan as long as I'm not copying
the expression of Matisse the expression
of Picasso there's no copyright
infringement so can you really copy the
idea you think that Bob Dylan's singing
style is not copyrightable I I think
it's not everything I think well but but
how many how many singers sound like Bob
Dylan lots of them all right Billy Joel
I mean if you're a fan of Billy Joel and
you're a fan of Bob Dylan and you know
Piano Man sing us a song You're a piano
man and then hey Mr tambry I mean
seriously and then I I've I've been to a
Billy Joel event where you sit and ask
questions with the guy and ask them so
what's the deal with piano man he's like
I love Bob Dylan right so I mean it but
we don't hold artists accountable for
the sorts of what what otherwise would
be right but but we're trying to hold AI
accountable for these sorts of
transgressions they're not really
they're just the way we do things I
think what happens is human people see
that a machine is doing exactly what we
did but in a computational way and then
we feel a lot less special about
ourselves and so an eject response is to
sort of go after you know find some
element of our uniqueness but the fact
is it's it's just not that's right it's
a variance and I would also say that
there's there's a trademark law right so
if I were to pass something off as Bob
Dylan or pass something off as you know
Billy Joel uh that would be trademark so
there's a bunch of cases where there's
uh there's uh uh Vanna White said that
you have a robot that looks like me
there's Tom Waits said you sound like me
so there's the trademark aspect of it
but the machine is not doing that you
know if I use chat you say right in the
style of Tom Wolf and then I put it out
as something that is Tom Wolf like that
might be a trademark infringement but
that would not be a copyright
infringement okay
well I think I think that
that's that's interesting because I
think there is case law
I can't put my finger on it immediately
where uh the the
expression the style of writing is in
fact the what got copyrighted in the
story content was nothing
the problem is
if you you know at least in my opinion
the copyright law does not really
differentiate things properly in a way
that that you can actually apply it the
same thing is true of uh adding the law
in some ways as well it's very very
difficult to uh to write a patent that
is uh bulletproof uh and doesn't uh
somehow have prior out out there that
will kill it
um it's it's it's hard and you know we
we chose the to maintain uh patterns of
protection which go back uh
100 years 200 years and more and it's
very difficult to have anticipated 200
years ago the uh the conflicts that we
have trying to figure out whether chat
GPT is uh is going to be able to be make
output which is copyright or not
um and in terms of what we're doing
today
I don't remember the exact number but I
think about half of Forbes Magazine is
generated by a computer from uh from
financial data without the interference
of any human being
um there is there's a guy that uh built
built a system that looked a lot like
GPT
um some years ago there's a professor at
North North Western and started a little
company and immediately got all the
major financial and sports magazines on
his uh his uh customer list and you
haven't heard of heard of him at all but
he puts out lots of magazine stuff
that goes to uh you cannot copyright
facts uh as well so if uh if a machine
is merely taking financial data facts
and then just expressing those facts uh
that is not copyrightable there's
nothing creative or original about
expression of facts but then it had it
had a knob
Financial commentator style which you
you wanted to use for each particular
article and so it's it's it's kind of
it's got to have some knowledge of what
the expression is in some sense because
it makes it something that's
recognizable by humans
and I suppose that that also
recognizable by a machine as a result
well we're coming up to 5 30 and I gotta
say I think I I really like this could
you uh say the last thing here and then
if everybody if everybody who talked
would send me their email address I'd
really appreciate that
thank you so yeah so because it's maybe
hard to uh understand maybe the
copyright and authorship concept this is
why I thought the awareness is much
easier and at the same time it has
similar impact to the authorship and the
copyright
um nonsense so that we kinda showed that
in this article AI participated because
of course data why artificial
intelligence is so powerful and good
because it can process much more data
than a human can so it can feeds on so
many different types of information and
we make sense of it or the AI May pre
make sense of it and then we kind of at
best it would be very favorable if we
control this process and say yes this is
correct conclusion this is maybe not so
this is why the awareness of for example
in the Articles we can uh point maybe
not even percentage that would be maybe
too good though can also raise questions
uh that yeah you did 30 percent as a
human but this 30 can have a big impact
uh so yes back to the awareness and it
may be a good solution as I said also
because
um we don't have to really go deeper
into what AI actually is but uh at the
same time it has similar impacts as the
authorship
um dispute
good
okay does anybody want to say the very
very last word
anyhow thank you very much it was really
I I I think this is a successful
experiment I I was uh really pleased
that we we ended up having a nice nice
collection of comments and I think we
actually moved the ball forward so and
thank you very much
and for your participation and uh
Carl good evening thank you
see you next week maybe